It's my great pleasure
to introduce,
Naso Kiriakov and
Vasil Momchev from,
our good friends, OntoText.
OntoText have been
in this space
a long time,
and really looking forward to
finding out the latest kind of
direction of the,
the the product that,
they've they've developed.
And I'll be moderating
this session.
Please, say hello,
introduce yourselves,
tell us where you're from,
and also don't hesitate to,
answer any questions,
and we'll,
we'll cover those
at the end. Great.
Welcome, Naso and, Vasil,
and and over to
you. Thank you.
Thank you very much, James.
It's indeed a great
pleasure to,
yeah, to be to
be again part of
this conference.
We have fresh
memories from one
year ago in London.
So, it will be
myself presenting
and and OntoTech's,
CTO, Vasil Mamcheff.
So I I I will I will entertain
you with a bit of
introduction of,
who we are,
and then I'll share our vision
on on the market for knowledge
gap technology and different
applications and how,
semantic metadata
are the key to put,
to for quite a number
of different
applications and
how how they,
can improve both
data management
and content management,
and and actually put data and
content together.
Then, I'll hand over to Vasil
to share with you, yeah,
few updates about,
Onstext platform
and and and our
database engine, Graph DB,
and to to to basically
walk you through,
the different aspects of what
it takes to to get
data in a graph
database, to to
transform them,
to make a proper
graph out of it,
and then to consume
them either
from whatever tool all the way
from BI tool,
that access data
to a JDBC driver
to another
application that use
use it through, say,
GraphQL or other APIs.
And then we'll finish off with
an overview of our partner
ecosystem because,
with the those wide range of
applications of
these technologies,
there is no single
vendor, at least,
no no no none of these,
specialized technology
providers,
who who can deliver
all the applications
to you.
So we built a partner
ecosystem,
to to to to be able to,
put the right technology stack
in place and to be able to to
to also deliver
it at at scale.
So let's get started
with the introduction
. So on to take this, yeah,
we started with,
what was back then
semantic weapon,
semantic technology
in year two
thousand. And we
had the chance
to to to be to be
part of the avant
garde in this technology and
went to the all the evolution
to link to open
data, nowadays,
knowledge gaps.
And, well, nowadays,
we are, like,
most of our clients,
are are the total leaders in
different industries
and markets,
like multinational companies.
Still, if we have
to to to come
to where where their
headquarters are,
it's quite an even
split between
UK where where we got
our first clients,
big clients in stories
ten years ago,
and, then US has
a growing area,
Asia also, and main,
mainland Europe.
Up until a year ago,
it was easy to say Europe.
Now you gotta say
Europe and UK.
But, anyway so,
you see some selection
of our clients.
I'll talk a bit more
about the verticals
, But, yeah, you see that most
of them are
precisely this type
of really big enterprises.
We we are not
allowed to mention
some of them,
but that's that's
the way it is.
We being being part of this
industry and part of the this
community that is,
developing the trends
and setting
the standards, we we do this
through through
a number of, yeah,
organizations, worldwide web
that we would see,
being the main one,
which not only standardizes
World Wide Web, HTML, HTP,
and all these
standards on which
the World Wide Web is built,
but they are also
the ones that
standardized RDS, Fargo, OWL,
and the stack of,
the stack of standards that we
we build our technology on.
And we have we
had the chance,
and we we are still
very happy to,
to keep pushing
our research to
a collaborative project.
So we are we are very,
very well interconnected with
those sorts of academic groups
in this field in Europe.
Our best, our most
popular product is,
Onstead's Graph DB.
We're getting, I don't
know, probably,
thousand or a bit
more downloads,
of, Graph DB per month.
And, yeah, we have an active
user community of more than
thirty thousand
deployed instances.
So there are plenty
of statistics
like that, and and we're happy
that we also see
recognition among,
yeah, different,
market analysts.
So, OnSpace GovDB
is seen as as
one one of the one
of the leading
engines in this field.
On top of this engine,
we actually have
a bigger set of,
a bigger platform,
knowledge graph platform,
called you wouldn't
guess it on
the text platform,
which extends what we get out
of Graph DB with,
analytics services
and infrastructure
for text analysis,
for data quality management,
and quite a few other things.
So, this platform,
yeah, helps you yeah.
It makes it much easier
to to to deploy,
to to make knowledge
center solutions.
But we'll talk about
the platform,
later on in this
presentation.
So stop here. On
the right hand side,
you see, yeah,
a business case or
or or the typical
solutions, that we offer and
that we can customize across
across different industries.
Like, historically,
we started with media
and publishing,
then we went to
financial services.
Life science and
health care is
a is a strong one too.
So to finish off
with the intro,
what makes us unique is this
combination of the graph graph
database engine,
which is suited for all all
kinds of use cases for for
knowledge graphs.
And the combination of this
database with text analysis,
services and
infrastructure tools,
like curation tools,
and manual
annotation tools and
so on and so forth
that can use
and are tuned to
use big knowledge
graphs for, text analysis.
As I said,
the entire portfolio
is based on, the double
two c stack of,
standards. And there is also
what if open source tooling as
part of this this
environment.
So the entire front end of our
database engine
is open source.
You can get it for kit,
use it for everything
you want.
Then the the plug in
API is open source.
We are supporter of
one of the leading
open source projects
in this space.
The probably
the biggest supporter
historically, are the four j,
also for text
analysis platforms,
and so on and so forth.
So we had the chance to to to
and I had the chance to gather
a team with a very,
very diverse set of,
skills and and
expertise across
different types of technology
and and science and
and verticals.
I'm not going to
list them because
that's not the purpose of this
this presentation.
Well, over time,
we realized that,
actually, the biggest
the biggest
asset and the most important
thing that we have is this
ecosystem of partners, which,
two years came to trust on to
text technology and work with
us in in in different ways.
So we have all all sorts of
consultants and OEM partners,
and we partner
with quite a few,
tool providers.
And and many of
these people are
actually present on
this conference.
So Symantecweb
company, MetaFacts,
and and and few others.
So, this was all in terms of
introduction. So
now let's talk
about the market.
If I gotta talk to to
to the investors,
the positive
message is, well,
this market is
doing very well.
If Gartner is saying that it
will be doubling
for another two
years two years,
That's that's just great.
And if you look at these,
hype cycles and curves,
you see knowledge graphs are
still still still going up,
so on the this peak of,
inflated expectations.
So, luckily, we're
still getting
people to who who are calling
us just because
knowledge graphs
are hot.
But we also see that,
and and and in this case,
I can agree with
with Gartner.
We see that, this trend,
is just about to to, yeah,
go go down to the yeah.
What what they
call disillusionment
because, yeah,
what is important
now is to see,
really a mature ways,
mature patterns,
best practices,
and and and tools which can be
used to deliver to
deliver value.
So on the bigger picture,
knowledge graphs
are the adoption
of this technology is slower
than what my investors would
want to see,
and probably yours
and and and,
everybody. The
fundamental reason
is that, well,
that this technology
is quite complex.
If you make it small,
if you just convert a piece of
data into into RDF,
or you convert the taxonomy in
and represent its
cost, very likely,
you'll you'll not
you'll not be
able to deliver on all these
promises of all
these knowledge
graph magic does.
So you you you have to use,
and make big knowledge graphs
that can really
provide provide
some context and
allow better better,
interpretation of the data and
bet better, like,
cap better capabilities for
linking data.
And once we get there, well,
it's not as as easy.
It takes a while,
a while to do it
to get the right
tooling and
the infrastructure to do it.
That's why it's it's,
our interpretation,
why it's slower
than expected.
We we others this by, yeah,
having prepackaged
solutions and
and partnering with,
other vendors who who have
solutions also.
So the short story
here is that,
well, there is no
single techno.
It's not a single,
single market.
Knowledge graph technology is
in the middle of other number
of different applications.
And, actually,
there is no mature
market for it now
because there
is no critical mass of such
applications. We we gotta make
the applications.
We gotta find our way to to to
to the end customers,
to to really
demonstrate the value
behind the hype.
And then five years from now,
we we we we we can
expect to see,
a a critical mass
of applications
that generates
a critical level
of demand for the technology.
So, it's clear that with all
the diversity of
what's possible
to do with this technology,
no no no single company of,
our size can can
deal with it.
Even much bigger
companies cannot
deal with this this scale.
So, again, our approach
to this is to,
have a have a ecosystem
of partners,
that can, that have the right
vision for
the specific type of
applications, and and and have
the engineering talent to
implement them,
taking into account
all the specifics
and the capacity to deliver.
That's quite often
a combination
of different players.
So, that's, yeah,
our mind map of
knowledge graph
applications. So, to to us,
knowledge graph is knowledge
graphs are on
the bigger picture
part of the bigger metadata
management story,
and the applications
go into, yeah,
equally between
data management
and content management.
There are plenty of knowledge
management tools
which also use
this technology,
and that's a big part of our
best partners, like,
Symantec Web Company
and Synoptica.
They are in in part of their
offerings are in the space of
enterprise taxonomies,
and and and,
vocabulary and this
kind of technology,
this time based
on on on on on,
yeah, knowledge gaps.
Quite often, these taxonomies
and vocabularies,
they are actually
used for better
content management.
This is
the the the the the applications
that you see on
the right hand side.
That's what Google
calls inside engines.
So so it's it's
all about being
able to do cool
things with content,
to to search, to recommend,
to to to re if
you're a publisher,
for instance, to to repackage
it and to to to
better deliver it,
to extract information,
to extract data from it,
and so on and so forth.
Nowadays, probably
the most, yeah,
the the the most
popular application,
although probably not the most
often delivered one,
is in data management.
So using using
knowledge graphs for,
data integration analytics.
And that's what,
Gartner called data fabrics.
That's that's
the whole story of,
what was the data warehouse in
the past and how you
can use them to,
yeah, do better
better business
intelligence and better
decision making.
Data management is
not just that.
It's actually much
more than this.
You have, a range of data
governance and cataloging
applications,
And quite a a big number of
these projects are are about,
dealing with big, databases,
like master and reference data
management tasks,
so that, yeah,
you can aid improve your
transactional systems either,
like in our case,
we we have many projects where
we use big volumes
of reference data,
master data for better text
analysis and content
content analytics.
So you see that, yeah,
the the range of applications
is quite different.
Essentially, each of these,
are already some
mature markets.
So, we we we have
to find a way
in which this, technology in
the middle can
contribute to to to,
to to making more efficient
specific applications
in this market,
and find a way to to, yeah,
gently disrupt them
and and and and,
offer you you you
value there.
So that's enough about it.
So to summarize the role of,
how we see the role
of knowledge graphs,
the main thing is
that they they
they essentially
put it in context,
and and and they do
it in two ways.
One thing is, linking.
So by
interlinking descriptions
of different things,
you you basically
help help help
different pieces contribute to
each other's description.
And then the other the other
thing is semantic metadata.
So semantic metadata
is is king.
So you you have better formal
descriptions of
everything that's
that's in there.
What is that value?
Well, someone gets
better better
insights, better
results, better,
discoveries, through,
through the capability,
by by by being able to have
unified view, on
diverse data.
Diverse databases
be being able
to combine,
structured data from
different sources,
being able to also
put in the mix
text documents and
other content.
And, well, quite often,
what we see is that to to get
the right level of analytics,
enterprises should combine
proprietary data with publicly
available data, with
with global data,
to combine their wisdom and
understanding of
the market with
background knowledge,
which can serve for better
interpretation. That's
that's what we,
deliver most of the time.
So, we combine, master data,
reference data from different
with the different sources,
what you see on the right hand
side in a knowledge graph,
and then we use this knowledge
graph to analyze documents.
Analyzing documents,
we produce metadata,
which becomes part
of the knowledge
graph. And this
way, we we put,
different kinds
of databases and
content together.
Obviously, there are plenty of
applications, and and benefits
of doing this both
on the content
management side and
and data management.
So metadata is king.
Metadata is everything.
If you listen to to Gartner,
metadata is, at
the middle of the,
yeah, next generation data
integration applications,
what they call data fabric.
So it's about
gathering different
types of, metadata,
putting them together,
structuring them,
interlinking them,
activating them,
and so on.
The important thing to realize
here is
the the diversity that,
you everything could be could
be metadata. It could be,
everything from
from the schema
of your your database to all
sorts of catalogs
or taxonomies
or reference data, tagging,
annotations of content,
operational logs,
and so on and so forth.
So it's really diverse.
You quite often need several,
many types of
metadata combined
from from different systems to
be able to to to
make a flexible
data integration platform or
content management.
I'm not going to read and,
through all these,
citations of Gartner.
The baseline is that the only
way to manage
this metadata and
to put it together is
a knowledge graph.
And, it is it is a semantic
knowledge graph.
The semantic approach having
formal descriptions of,
this metadata that
helps you put
data and content together.
So the RDS tech
web technologies
allows you to do
all this, in well.
And there there are several
features of the standards in
this tech which contribute to
this all the way from having
global identifiers,
which is key for
interoperability.
Formal semantics is really
important because,
it it allows sharing
meaning and and,
interpretation
without ambiguities
and and and, basically
enables enables,
much much better analytics and
combining different
analytic techniques.
Standardization is, yeah,
someone that everyone in in
enterprise data management,
enterprise content
management,
needs and wants
unless you want
to stick with
a single vendor.
And, yeah, at
the end of the day,
it's always about quality and
being able to
maintain quality.
So, also so all
means for, like,
RDF shapes and
other techniques
for validation are
very important.
All these things are missing
with the property
graph standard.
So, they they do
great great job
for for graph analytics,
but there is essentially no
standardization, and there is
no notion of semantics.
There is even no
notion of schema.
There is no data
schema language.
So it's obvious
that RDF is much
much better suited
for knowledge gaps,
and that's what we hear from,
our clients
being predominantly
enterprise date
data architects.
We have built the methodology
of everything that
that it takes to,
build in a and and
if of knowledge
graph all the way
from requirement
analysis, data gathering,
and so on and so forth to,
putting together
semantic data model,
integrating the data,
reconciling the data,
cleaning the data,
and then being able to store,
index them, enrich them,
make them accessible,
and, unable,
updates and be
able to maintain
this knowledge graph.
Once once you come
with such a complex
phenomenon, it's,
not a piece of cake to keep it
in good shape and good quality
and be able to make
all the updates
that are necessary.
So we introduced
the On-tech platform,
which supports
quite quite a big
fraction of this tech.
Everything that is about,
allowing data architects and
everyone who who data
management people,
to collaborate with content
management people and deliver
value for the business
users and
the data scientists,
which are quite
often the consumers
of this technology,
as part of
downstream models or
people who train
specific machine
machine learning,
models on it.
Quite important to all here is
dedicated to to
business analysts
and subject matter experts.
So, part part for offering,
is a set of tools
that that allows,
defining APIs and
interfaces and
specifying, views
on this on this,
knowledge graph in the middle
by experts, by
business analysts.
So so you don't
don't need a a big
team of,
programmers to to
code middleware.
With this,
I'll finish my part
of the presentation.
I want to hand
over to Vasil to
tell you some updates about
the OnText platform
and and Graph DB.
I'll stop sharing
so that Vasil
can take over.
Thanks for
the excellent market
overview and giving
us all the complexity
of the market of
around the knowledge
graphs and how we can deliver
these type of solutions.
As database provider,
when we meet clients,
often we are asked, okay.
I understand the concept of
agreeing cohort
shared identifiers
for classes, instances,
and some predicates,
which identify the meaning of
our organizational data.
But could you tell
me how should
I put the data in Gravity,
in your database,
and how I should
really develop
applications on top of it?
And this is probably the most
frequent question we get from
our clients when they expect
really some sort of a mature
tooling around the technology
in order to quickly
develop solutions.
In this my presentation,
I'm going to share five key
highlights which has happened
this year of twenty twenty,
And these are really the major
developments and
tools we which
we enable our
clients to develop
and partners, of course,
to develop faster and better
knowledge graph solutions.
So the first one
is really the data
virtualization,
which gives you
a virtual sparkle
endpoint access
to the different databases.
Then we enable
the mapping with
the mapping new
mapping UI subject
matter export
with no coding to
generate RDF
models around some
skimmers. Then I will speak
about the data
reconciliation,
how you really
need to integrate
multiple datasets,
which speaks about
the same type
of entities.
Then we we go to
the consumption
of the data. Once we
have the knowledge
graph, how you
can let your data
scientists and
business analysts
to consume the data.
And last but not least,
I'm going to
introduce the GraphQL
platform, which
gives you a really
fantastic way how
you can design
APIs also for your application
solution developers,
and there is an automatic way
to interact with the knowledge
graph with really
minimal calling.
Okay. First thing first,
data virtualization.
Nearly all enterprise data is
still stored in
relational databases,
and there is a good
reason there
because these are
transactional systems,
master reference records,
where the information
is primarily
stored. The most
logical question
is how I can move
the data from
relational databases
into a knowledge
graph, basically.
And we give you two
type of use cases.
The first type of use case is
I want to make a decorative
transformation of
the relational
database into RDF,
or I want to access
the database
on the file. In
order to enable
this use case, Graphvini nine
dot five integrates
with the on
top framework, which supports
decorative, descriptors like
the and the OBDA,
which are part of the On top
project to give
you all the fly
access to a wide range of
relational models
like Postgres,
DRAMU Oracle, MySQL,
Microsoft SQL Server,
really a big range
of technologies.
In order the design
decision we
took was to expose
every virtual
every relational
database as its
own virtual
repository in order
to make the data locality very
transparent for the users.
This made the users
fully aware
that they are
accessing different
type systems. However,
in order to optimize
the performance,
we implement
the highly efficient
internal federation,
where if you federate two
endpoints which are located on
the same CloudDB Server,
you use a highly efficient
internal protocol
for data exchange.
The benefit is that you get to
this on top integration also
integrated with
all the security
features and the the Graph DB
security model,
single sign on,
and all these type
of functionalities.
So the second
feature is really
mapping UI,
how you can let your subject
matter experts and the people
knowing the data
without coding
to populate
the knowledge graph.
How many of your organizations
have most of the critical data
in some sort of
a spreadsheet,
CSV file, or
something which is
used as a reference model?
Using the open refine tool,
which is nicely
integrated with
open with Graph
DB and Graph DB
Workbench, you
can transform any
type of structure that you are
form of JSON, XML,
CSVs, g files,
whatever you have,
and it gives you an efficient
way to clean and
cluster the data.
Usually, once you
start with any
type of CSV or Excel files,
there is a really
sort some type
of cleaning. This is nicely
integrated with CloudDB so you
can create a project
with the table
of data. On the right side,
you can see the new
mapping interface,
which checks what are the word
ontologies in the repository,
and it can guide the user what
are the product predicates and
the properties sorry,
the types to use in order to
generate a mapping,
which is then transformed
into RDF file.
So from this table or data,
you can really record this as
a structure. You you basically
say how you
transgenerate the RDA
values and how
these values are
connected. As a next step,
it supports two modes.
One is really the interactive
mode where the user can,
preview the information,
clean it,
check what we
would the output.
But, also, it
supports the tool
supports to batch everything,
to record
the transformations,
and really to
make it sound and
transparent using
a batch script.
Also, the API
supports streaming
data streaming where you can
batch really big
files and process
them on demand.
The third big
feature is the data
reconciliation, and this is
the case when you have to
integrate multiple datasets
sharing the same identifiers.
Once again, our focus is to
subject matter experts and how
without code to
perform the entity
resolution. The
data resolution
is the entity resolution is
actually matching
entities into
different type of, tables.
And we say this
is a mapping of
string two things.
By using
the graph connectivity
and the schema,
this gives you really a power
of subject matter
experts in a stepwise
process to say how you can
reconcile the data.
On your screen,
you see some
American US banks,
and the task is really to find
the right ID in dataset,
like QuickiData or whatever.
So why this is
an efficient work
process and it
requires no calling?
Because the subject
matter experts
can start reconciling
the state.
Like you see on the diagram,
the reconciling the US states
is an easy task because there
is no big community.
Then you can go to the cities
by using the state,
which should use the,
in the because the,
cities are connected
to the states.
Later on, at the final step,
you need to really reconcile
the organization
and pick the right
organization.
Next, let's imagine that you
have the knowledge
graph and you
passed all the hurdles to put
the data in a knowledge graph
and the RDL databases.
But the next
question is, hey.
I have a big data
scientist and
knowledge engineer team,
and none of them knows Parco.
They're really
good with business
BA type of tools
like Tableau,
Microsoft Power BI.
Could you just export
me a spreadsheet
and a table in where
I can analyze it?
No. This is really a forward
approach because if you you'll
be replicating data,
which is wrong.
Now browDB comes with
the JDB access,
which enables all
type of tools
which supports JDBC
like Tableau,
Microsoft BI,
to directly interact
with the data
and to connect,
investigate what
are the tables.
And you can directly visualize
and take the data out
of the database.
The way how we do this is we
define SQL views,
which are basically
SPARQL results.
In these SPARQL results,
there is a nice user interface
where you put your
SPARQL query,
you say what is
the SQL table name,
and the interface,
depending on the data
distribution,
guides you how to
use this right
SQL types in order
to get the results.
At the end so below
you see a one
technicality is
that this driver
will also try to push as much
as possible of the complexity
down to the database.
So if you have work logs in
the SQL query,
it will be pushed
down to the sparkle
in order to
minimize the exchange between
the SQL engine and
the RTL database.
Last but not least,
this is really
a very big topic.
Autotech invested
in a platform
based on GraphQL,
how you can really expose how
you can expose
knowledge graphs
and quickly build
and generate APIs.
One of the main challenges is
once you design any
type of a system
is that you need to
plan for the APIs,
and these APIs needs to be
synchronized with
the scheme of
the model.
Now the Graph DB and the now
the auto text
platform can read
the data with using this auto
text platform workbench,
the schema of the of
the graph database,
and automatically
generate the Graph
QL API for you.
Using this GraphQL API,
you can select what are only
the required
permitted operations
in order to control the access
to the data.
By for bridging
the GraphQL to RDF,
Autotext develops some really
key features. One
is really a highly
efficient graph to
sparkle translation.
This seems as an easy task,
but in order to get
the full complexity,
we have tweak the semantic
the semantics
of SPARQL and having a special
execution mode,
which makes this
really efficient.
Also, this is a bidirectional
mapping where we're
using mutations,
which can be
also automatically
generated. You
can interact with
the data and modify it,
directly from the GraphQL.
This is really
very good if you
have UI applications who need
some which needs some sort of
data validation or
access control,
which is also supported
over the schema.
What's point here is,
this I'm not sure how many of
you are familiar
with the GraphQL
ecosystem, but
there is another
excellent feature,
which is the GraphQL
federation,
which allows
the integration of
third party services.
This is a service
level integration
of the acquired data
visualization,
but for other type
of services.
Since this is
a very broad topic
and I don't have time
to go in details,
I really invite you to join
the later session,
which will be led
by Jim Rayfield,
our chief solution, Arhite,
who can give you in the deep
technicalities of GraphQL
federation and
knowledge graphs
and how you can control your
knowledge graph
via the GraphQL
APIs and how you
open the spectral
chaos. Okay. Thank you.
I give it now back to Naso to
continue with the partner
ecosystem and how all these
tooling and key features we
develop as
a successful business
model using our partners.
Thank you, Vasil.
Although, yeah,
we we we have a very capable
database engine, and we have,
a platform on top of it that
that provides a lot
of infrastructure
and technology,
we still cannot
cover everything
that you may want to do with
the knowledge graph, and,
before start speaking
of applications.
So, to address this, we have,
a range of portfolio
partners,
which are companies
like Symantec
Web Company,
Synaptica, MetaFacts,
the sensor, Omni,
Memotix, Workbench,
quite a number of partners who
provide tools and platforms
which integrate Graph DB.
And and and, this way,
we complement each
other's portfolio,
and we can much
better add the the
full stack of needs
for this technology.
Beyond that,
we we we work
quite a lot with,
different kind of
consulting partners.
So we work with,
some of the biggest,
IT service,
providers and system
integrators on Earth.
On the list there,
you have, like,
Infosys, WIPO,
Auto SentiData,
Fujitsu. These are
five of the top
ten biggest IT
services companies,
and, they they
are familiar with
the technology and and and
delivery to to to big clients
all the way from government to
to pharma and back.
We also have, much, yes,
more specialized,
let's call them
boutique consulting
and delivery partners, like,
data language in in UK and
enterprise knowledge
in in US,
Southworks in Korea,
and and and many others.
So, this is an ecosystem that
currently consists
of more than
fifty partners.
So, we will not try
to list all of them,
and we took care to to to put
it right on for all kinds of,
agreements to to make to make
this ecosystem
operate, properly.
So, yeah,
we're looking forward to join
other partners to complement
the even further,
the ecosystem with either
consulting delivery skills,
either a a a, yeah, tools.
And this this good point,
to to invite you
to the webinar.
Vasu, if you can go
to the next slide.
The the the the webinar that,
will take place in
twenty minutes.
That's part of
the promotion to
party eight of our partner,
Semantic Web Company.
You see that Vasil
is having a very
intensive day today.
So he'll finish here,
and he'll be part of,
the webinar that
starts in twenty
minute with minutes
with Pu party eight.
So, it will be it
will essentially
show how, yeah, yeah,
the integration between pool
party eight and
and and and and
Gravity makes pool party much
better performant and,
improves on on
the scalability side.
And we also
demonstrate, Vasil,
I think you gotta press next
because there is
some animation.
Okay. Part of this
demo will be,
well, we have a we
we we have a,
new stacking
service scope now,
and it works with
giant technology
graph derived from
Wikidata, geo names,
Wikipedia, whatever.
And we use it to
analyze news articles.
So part of this
service will be
a demonstration
of how you can,
tune the performance,
the the the the behavior
of this,
very sophisticated natural
language processing
text analysis
pipeline by,
doing small
corrections to this
knowledge graph
with pool party
eight and immediately see
improvement of results.
In this way, we we show how
voice management
and tailor made
vocabularies, and and,
expert work can
can can combine
and can deliver
value in combination
with very big
knowledge graphs.
So it's it's
a work with them.
We've been and we're I've been
working half half life to make
this possible,
so you you still
have a chance to join
in twenty minutes.
And that's just one
of our partners.
We are very happy with our
partnership with
Symantec Web company.
So join the webinar
if you wanna pursue,
and, the the people
from Semantic
Web Company tell
you more about it.
That's everything from us.
Thank you very much for your
time and attention.
Massive, thanks to
Naso and, Vasil.
It's really
interesting to see.